survey the audience our single fathers
hypocrites for avoiding single moms with
dating
and uh no they're not was the vast
majority now granted
most of most of the guys that watch my
channel are dudes yeah
um there's not as many uh women but
let's check out the comments here
because this usually sorts it by the top
comments
on twitter oh twitter will just break
the internet if you put it there because
it's where the
that's where the out that's where the
outrage mobs
um dude here says i'm a single dad in my
last relationship
ended because the single mother i was
dating didn't like the fact that my time
and attention went to my own child
instead of her kid
every other weekend it didn't matter
that i spent more time taking care of
her kid
than my own even even going so far
as to demand that i take my ex-wife back
to court and
fight for full custody so as to
eliminate my son's mother from the
equation
two problems with that i'm a guy to
california
bonus like you know she's making demands
on his life
with his you know with his own kids uh
bonus reason and what leverage does she
have i don't understand why they think
you have this leverage to just make
these demands
well it's because they have the leverage
and they think that it'll work the other
way right
it's like you know it's a blanc's blank
slate for everybody men and women are
the same
no they're not men and women are
different and that's okay
um risk making matters worse with the
ex-wife and ruining my relationship with
my son
so she basically wanted to throw a huge
monkey wrench in what he had going on
with his parenting schedule
it didn't matter how many diapers i
changed bass i'd given dinner's cook
trips home from daycare i've made all
that time and attention i gave to
another man's kid only for him to
inevitably grow up and tell me
you're not my dad i don't have to listen
to you
cold hard facts right um
men can discipline his children he can't
discipline her children especially a
girl
one false accusation and his life is
destroyed
uh let's just read one more here this
guy says as a single father i feel that
every dollar and every minute i have to
spend should be spent on my son not
somebody else's child
that's just how it is getting involved
with a single mother means resources of
time and money are inevitably going to
get diverted away from my own
simple but true is what it is right
i mean i like
i get the plate and by the way for those
of you guys that are in the waiting area
uh just leaving the private chat what
your question is or if it's a comment if
you want to challenge us whatever
just leave a quick private chat there
and i'll get to you guys in a second but
i get the plight you know like they're
like okay we you know we deserve love
too
we want to get involved as well and
you're telling guys to stay away from
single moms even though you're a single
dad you're a hypocrite okay well you can
point and spider if you want
the fact is i've got way more money than
you you know you've got your kids most
of the time because women get 80
of the custody orders still which means
over the course of a month they've got
the kids 80
of the time so a lot of these fathers
sometimes find themselves in a scenario
where um they don't get to see their
kids that often and they spend more time
parenting
somebody else's kids yeah and what ends
up happening is
they end up being their kids when she
needs something
money resource attention pay for a car
trip whatever but they're his kids when
you know it's the opposite right or
there her kids
if he needs to discipline them so
there's a lot of things that pop up with
this it just
it just becomes pretty problematic
you